[Music]
you need more women
out there supporting women girl power
[Music]
glamour's given me a lot it's given me a
voice they're the first magazine that
was like
just be you
to be able to give women a platform
where we can be acknowledged
we can be appreciated and see
reflections of ourselves
it's been wrong i cannot be kid man
i'm kid woman thank you
[Music]
hello i'm deborah joseph editor-in-chief
of glamour
and i'm delighted to welcome you to the
2021
glamour women of the year awards coming
to you from the court in london's quiet
soho we are so delighted to celebrate
20 years of glamours highlighting the
achievements
of incredible women as we've always done
but the fact that this coincides around
international women's day
makes it even more special and on that
note i'd like to welcome
our brilliant host for this evening
comedian
catherine ryan thanks debra it's been
four long arduous years since the last
glamour women of the year awards
but like american democracy we're back
oh great now we're like 90s plush and
backs
yeah i'm the romy to your michelle as
deborah said
glamour's women of the year awards has a
proud history of recognizing phenomenal
and inspirational women
and 2020 was a year like no other not
only because of the global health crisis
and the sharply accelerated economic
downturn
but also because we stopped carrying
handbags and shunned our bras
like a resurgence of the 1970s women's
liberation movement
but with less fire and more
homeschooling ah
it was nothing like the women's
liberation movement for me i spent the
whole time trapped in the house
compulsively loading
the dishwasher yes but crucially without
a bra
bye without a bra okay
and i also had to listen to my aunt
susan become an infectious disease
expert overnight
that's been a real treat yet while our
government continued to deny science
so many phenomenal women across the
globe stood up
spoke out and shattered glass ceilings
everywhere oh
good in recognition of these
extraordinary times we've created
extraordinary awards
focused on extraordinary women who have
and who are
changing the game forever which is why
we're renaming tonight the glamour women
of the year awards 2021
the game changers and these awards are
inclusive
so inclusive in fact that we have
decided
one of our awards will be presented to a
man
sure men's voices are shrill and
irritating but perhaps that's because we
aren't used to hearing from them
in political briefings or boardroom
meetings
so when the time comes please be
respectful
and give the little lad your undivided
attention
lesson okay you can go change now oh
thank god
nothing fits me anymore since i moved my
office so close to the fridge
our first award of the night goes to our
new gen game changer
the woman who wins this award has used
her voice to change opinions on
screen and off and she doesn't think
twice when it comes to standing up for
her community
encouraging her peers to vote or
tackling gun crime
it's none other than the outstanding
actor model and activist
yara shahidi hi all it's yara and i
wanted to start by saying
thank you because i am so honored to be
here and to be one of the honorees
amidst a group of people that i
genuinely so admire to get a game change
reward is pretty surreal especially just
turning 21
and it makes me reflect on the people
that have supported me in order to be
able to have the space to do what i love
to do so much
i think of the ways in which much of
what i do is not new but of anything
inherited from the work of prior
generations
it also makes me reflect on the words of
one of my favorite humans
james baldwin in which he talks about
the role of the artist as being the role
of
illuminating a path amidst darkness of
reaffirming our purpose
and i'm grateful to be in a position in
which through my art and through my
spaces outside of my work
i'm able to constantly talk about what
matters to me and constantly help
in the fight towards equity i can say
for certain
that i am one of many humans and if
anything i am more inspired by the fact
that i am one of many faces
and my generation continues with such
passion
and such vigor lead the way and innovate
on new ways
to fight for justice i could not be
luckier than to land in gen
z because every time i don't feel
helpful
i look in front of me i look to my left
to my right and i see sources of
inspiration
i can't wait to see the world that we
reimagined together and
i am looking forward to being a small
part of it much love to everybody
and thank you again
congratulations to yara next up is our
beauty game changer
she hit our screens in 2016 as 11 in
stranger things
and has gone on to challenge the beauty
industry setting up her
own clean beauty range florence by mills
which is non-toxic vegan sustainable and
cruelty free and at just 14 she was the
youngest ever person to take on the role
of a unicef
ambassador it's millie bobby brown
hi everyone i hope you and your loved
ones are safe and healthy
i am honoured to be receiving glamour
uk's beauty game changer award
a year and a half ago i created florence
by mills
a clean beauty and skincare brand with
one message at its core
beauty is about loving and expressing
ourselves
defying beauty on our own terms no rules
no struggle toward perfection no beauty
standards
just us playing with how we want to look
feel
and live looking forward my hope is that
everyone of all ages
continues to spread love and kindness
which is another way beauty can take
shape thank you again to glamour uk
for this amazing achievement and award
i'm so excited to put it up
and to look at it as a reminder that
beauty is whatever
you are beauty is whatever you define it
as
and i can't wait to change the game
at 14 i'd been awarded the highest
number of sanctions for wearing my
uniform skirt too short
you and me both my headmaster said i'd
been distracting the boys with my attire
well that was part of my world
domination plan but that is an
incredibly archaic attitude that
perpetuates misogyny
and suggests that boys behaviors and
reactions are the responsibilities of
their female peers i know
i knew that maybe you take the next one
yeah
sure on to our game-changing model award
in 2020 this woman captivated the world
when she fronted her first major fashion
campaign for gucci
the first ever model with down syndrome
to do so
and last year she was one of our very
own glamour
cover stars ladies and token gentlemen
we are proud to present this award to
the star that is
ellie goldstein
[Music]
i think i want to be a model all the
time
because i love to be myself
and i i would never give
up i want gucci to
use me again because i hope
that um other people with
disabilities they look up to me and i
think they'd like to see me in a couple
of magazines
well i think my style is pretty like
uh jessie sassy
i think like styles like clothes like
dresses or skirts
or tights and pajamas
the difference is before i
was a bit shy i know but for now
i'm all confident i'm all prepared
thank you grandma for this ordinary
awards
thank you so much i love you guys love
you
bye
since 1981 almost 33 million people
around the world have died from
aids-related illnesses
yet there's still a lot of miseducation
around the subject
however our next award goes to a woman
whose role
in channel 4's it's a sin has been
praised for representation of allyship
to the lgbtq plus community
shedding light on a much needed subject
and challenging the stigma that still
exists today
our game-changing rising star in
partnership with gerlar
goes to lydia west hi
i'd like to say a huge thank you to
glamour for this award
i would like to dedicate it to russell t
davis for creating such a beautiful
drama
and beautiful character who we all fell
in love with and i'd like to say a
massive thanks to jill nordah for a
while
being jill the work of allies is super
important
as they are the voice between the the
minority and the majority and it's their
job to connect these voices and fight
for equal rights
so this award is to all the allies out
there all these unsung heroes
we love you and we respect and cherish
you forever
i'd like to thank the cast and crew of
it's a sin for being
so amazing and honor those lives that's
sadly no longer with us because of hiv
and aids on that note we can all be more
jill
and finally
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
last year was unprecedented and
impactful
the footage of george floyd being
suffocated as police officer derek
chauvin knelt on his neck for eight
minutes and 46 seconds
will never leave us the mental and
emotional toll that so many in the black
community experience
living in a systemically racist society
is often overlooked
or ignored entirely which is why our
next two winners wanted to come together
and
open up the conversation this year's
charity game changer goes to the
founders
of the remarkable black minds matter
agnes mwakatuma
and annie nash whose mission is to
connect black individuals and families
with free mental health services
while the winner of our game-changing
influencer award
goes to a woman who is changing the
world for the better by putting
transgender rights on the mainstream
agenda
but unlike our own prime minister she
holds the floor with poise
style and great hair while doing so
it is the legend that is monroe bergdorf
hi hi monray i'm doing how's 2020 being
free
um i think for me especially in relation
to bmm is the different conversations
that were happening
after the very sad murder of george
floyd
that time kind of allowed us all to
pause to really sit down and to really
pay attention
to what was really going on in the
different ways that black people were
still being oppressed not only in the us
but also the uk
yeah we're experiencing such a plethora
of issues that all
point back to white supremacy just even
listening to that
consistently over this year it's a lot
this is the most isolated that we've
ever been in our lives
from each other and the most time that
we've ever spent on social media we
don't even know how social media affects
us mentally in the long run with social
media and activism
as much as you go into it with such good
intentions and you really want to help
it does like social media does end up
kind of asking far too much of you than
you are willing to give
there's this pressure isn't there for
everyone to be an activist especially if
you're
a marginalized person i've gotten to the
point now where
i need a little time away from social
media
i want my activism to be plugged into
the organizations that i work with
and i can't do that if i'm consistently
being pulled into
every single social media debate you
can't pour from an empty cup
you can't last year taught me so much
about not just my power but the power of
community
the power of addressing issues of racism
but most importantly the ways in which
systemic race is important to the
healthcare system
people would be really surprised how
many obstacles
marginalized people face in the
healthcare system because
the job of a healthcare professional is
to treat everybody equally but that just
doesn't happen
because the thing with the implicit and
unconscious bias is
you don't know it my mom's white and i
had to explain to her
the importance of having a black
therapist when you
go to a therapist and they don't
understand what it's like to be a black
woman or what it's like to be
a black trans woman or a black queer
trans woman
you end up explaining more than you
should have to
and then that's time that you could use
actually
working through your trauma convincing
people who aren't trans
and who aren't often black that you
are a black trans person and i say a
black trans person because our
experience is very unique
especially in the uk where only three
percent of this country
is black and only one percent of this
country is trans
so we're a minority of a minority not
enough
people that are gatekeepers essentially
of how we see ourselves
um you know of our ability to transition
medically
they're not really aware of the
realities of you know the power that
they wield
and how at risk a lot of trans people
really are
definitely i think we need the
healthcare industry to kind of be
vetting people more
not just going on qualifications but
also going on what that person
um truly believes in what their thoughts
are on equality what their thoughts are
on gender and sexuality because those
are very important topics it's it's
about the holistic experience
of minorities i feel and lifting up the
most marginalized members
of society because if we're centering
them
then everybody wins everybody wins also
just the responsibility of us to also
ensure that we are
standing up against other forms of
racism against other
kind of groups we can't just be for
black racism thank you so much for this
award game changing influencer
we've got a long way to go but we're
getting there so this
is um really really special to me thank
you very much
thank you so much glamour for this award
on behalf of everyone at black minds
mata uk
it's so nice to know that so many of us
are committed to changing the face of
black mental health
so thank you so much for being a part of
this journey
i'm sure someone will dm me what the
notice our next winner
is an actor comedian rapper author and
tv host
and an all-around badass who last year
was the first woman of asian descent to
win a golden globe in a lead actress
category
for her role in the farewell and tonight
she takes home the award for game
changing creator
it is of course aqua athena
uh hold for one second and i'm gonna
grab a piece of paper i'm gonna i'm
gonna use my ipad
just close out of the angry birds and
whatnot first thing
that i created when i was a kid
were two imaginary friends they were
named
charlie and madonna she looked
she wore the pee-wee herman suit and i
would blame them on everything
i think a lot of things different things
have inspired me different parts of my
life
a book of charles bukowski's uh poems
margaret show the first time i saw
margaret cho doing stand up was the
first time
i'd seen an asian and american woman um
that was
on that stage like uh doing stand-up and
lucy lou and charlie's angels
who is a goddess and continues to be and
my grandma
obviously love her but i i really am
just like free drawing this is bizarre
i really didn't think that i was good
for anything and i remember always
feeling like
you know maybe my problem isn't that i
i'm not capable of doing those things
but what if i never love something so
much that i'll do it
forever but then there was a moment uh
while i was filming
i started to realize that i did fulfill
those goals that that i never thought
that i would as a child
simply by finding something that i
would lose sleep over that i uh would
drive myself crazy over that that i
would cry over that i would
um feel so much joy over i was i was
drawing as i was talking to you and like
reaching back into the inner depths of
my mind and i didn't plan any of this
first of all what's wrong with my shoes
what's wrong with there's nothing wrong
with those yes they look like little
loaves of bread
but delicious ones yeah she doesn't look
right but it is abstract
oh oh and it went and it went away i am
winning
i am winning today um
thank you so much glamour uk for the uh
game-changing creator
award of okay well i said i said he
award i'm so sorry thank you so much
glamour uk
for uh the honor of this award the the
game changing creator award
my whole life has been has been about a
desire to change the game
and i think when uh we dare to do so
we make a better game thank you glamour
uk
uh for supporting powerful cool women
did i call myself a powerful cool woman
just now
oh god
a huge congrats to aquafina fun fact
aquafina began rapping at 13 and was let
go from her pr job at a publishing house
after creating the rap video
my vag so it just goes to show that to
be a
true game changer you gotta take risks
and now it's time for a musical
interlude not you
discovered at the age of 12 she has
amassed 21
platinum singles 900 million youtube
views
and 3 billion streams worldwide her
voice has been described as youthful and
fragile
like a type of winged warm-blooded
vertebrate
it's birdie thank you so much for
inviting me to grandma's women of the
year awards
i'd like to play you the new single from
my upcoming album yamaha
this is secondhand news
[Music]
hello
[Music]
me is
[Music]
good
[Music]
since the day you've been gone
[Music]
if
these bridges
[Music]
but it doesn't mean
[Music]
is
[Music]
bridges
[Music]
good
[Music]
a huge thank you to birdie many people
dream of writing a book
our next winner not only turned her
dreams into reality many times over
she's also the first ever black woman
and black brit
to win the booker prize for her
masterpiece girl
woman other over the past 20 years
she has been a prominent advocate for
diversity and inclusion
and she is currently curating a new
series called black britain
writing back rediscovering works about
black britain over the past
century our game-changing author is the
inspirational
bernadine evaristo
where do you think the future of black
british writing is
you know the dolls are opening and
that's amazing they're opening in a way
that's
never happened before i want to see our
writers writing
everything from every perspective every
genre
because at the moment we've tended to
write literary fiction
there is a smaller audience for that but
our writers need to also be writing
really commercial books
that reach audiences and readers of
millions
even yeah it's really about highlighting
the diversity of the black british
experience so we're not just
you know perpetually portrayed as a
monolith that's right because we're as
diverse as any other
demographic out there and it's very
interesting because
one of the things about girl with
another is that people are surprised at
the diversity of the characters within
the novel
but what it does is it opens up the
possibilities of who we are in this
society
and that's what i'd like to see
happening for black people
and black women and people of color in
in britain
what have been your other game changing
moments
i think the first one
was getting published by my current
publishing house penguin
i had gone from the smallest publisher
in the world to the largest publisher in
the world
and that changed a lot in terms of how i
was perceived
and how my books were able to reach
audiences
and then willian the booker of course
in 2019 changed everything beyond my
wildest imagination
suddenly i became really well known
as a writer globally and all the things
that i could wish for my career came to
me
thank you glamour for this wonderful
game-changing author award
i'm totally delighted to receive it and
to have this kind of acknowledgement for
my work
so thank you so much
next up the man who really makes it
sting when tax season rolls around
and i learned that zero of my government
owed money is going to feed
britain's hungry children like i
reasonably assumed that it would
in a compassionate society he is a
tireless campaigner for homelessness
hunger and literacy and who in just 24
hours last june
forced the government to u-turn on their
carefully considered decision to end
free school meals for children from
disadvantaged backgrounds
and in his spare time he plays for
manchester united
and england our game-changing man
is the undeterred marcus rashford
hi guys i just wanted to say a big thank
you to glamour for the game changing
man of the year award
our entrepreneurial game changer award
goes to a businesswoman in a class of
her
own after starting her career as a
makeup artist she founded her own beauty
company huda beauty in 2013 and last
year
it was valued at an eye-watering 1
billion
she has been named one of the 10 most
powerful beauty influencers by forbes
and one of the 25 most influential
people on the internet by time magazine
it's huda katan i'm so
incredibly humbled to receive your
entrepreneurial game changer award
i am such a fan of glamour and i love
being on the cover so much it's a
magazine that's changed my life in so
many ways
and as a young girl who loves beauty so
much i would go to the magazine
constantly to find
so many tips and tricks and always
wanted to be you know somebody who could
be as glamorous as somebody who would be
in glamour makeup and beauty has been
such a big journey for me
um you know i've talked about my story
in makeup and beauty and how
it really transformed my life so much i
was able to become
a character in it and really actually
become myself which was really amazing
for me beauty is something that's going
to continue to grow it's going to
continue to inspire people it's going to
touch people so much
but also you know with beauty standards
the world has changed in such a way
because of social media because of you
know our voices that
you know we've democratized beauty we
need to do it so much more
and i feel like that's happening and i'm
really really proud of where the
industry is going to go
thank you so much glamour for this
incredible award i love you guys so much
bye
mental health may be something that
we're more comfortable talking about now
but that wasn't the case when almost a
decade ago our next winner publicly
spoke about her mental health struggles
for the first time
with glamour she's continued to talk
openly about her ongoing battle with
depression
anxiety and suicidal thoughts our mental
health
game changer is singer presenter and
writer
frankie bridge i always say that i'm
someone that was born anxious
as i grew up in the public eye i
realized that i
didn't have much control over my own
life and it got to a point where
i felt like i was coming into work and i
was
being frankie from the saturdays rather
than just
frankie one person i
started feeling i didn't want to be
around anymore i didn't want to live my
life anymore
i wasn't able to cope with um day-to-day
normal life without
crying i found i wanted to spend all my
time in bed and just kind of hide away
that was when i realised that maybe my
depression and my anxiety had taken over
me
rather than me having control over it
i chose glamour magazine to speak to
about
my mental health it just seemed right at
the time i felt like they were going to
be sensitive to the subject
and they really were they really got it
there was part of me that chose to do
the interview to kind of say
oh actually i was in hospital because i
had anxiety and depression and this is
my story
but obviously i wanted to help others to
open up
and seek help where they needed to and
and it did that the fact that people
still come up and tell me about that one
interview and glamour magazine just
means so much to me
i can remember watching my son bouncing
on a trampoline
and the pure joy and excitement of just
that simple thing
just made me realize you know as you get
older you don't appreciate those little
things
seeing life through a child's eye
is just amazing um
so they make me extremely happy some
days not so much
thank you so much glenna for my mental
health game changer award
it means so much to me it's so nice to
know that
just by having honest and open
conversations
you feel like i'm helping people and
this award is just
the cherry on the top so thank you so
much
well done to frankie when the next woman
learned about girls missing school
because they couldn't afford basic
sanitary wear
aged just 17 she took on the uk
government
and two years later the chancellor of
the exchequer announced that secondary
schools in england
would receive funding to provide
sanitary products to those who need them
she continues to tackle the stigma of
menstruation while studying history at
cambridge
she is amica george and she is our
justice game changer
i want to say a huge huge thank you to
glamour for this award thank you so much
i think it's incredible that activism is
being recognized and it's important it's
really being celebrated in 2021
in a year when there are so many
possibilities for creating change
thank you glamour
ballin thank you nice you've upped your
game as well
oh yeah i decided to put on matching
sweats this time
the next award is for our sports game
changer which goes to naomi osaka
she's the first tennis player of asian
descent to hold the top rank in the
singles
a three-time grand slam and reigning u.s
open champion
as well as being ranked the highest
earning female athlete of all time
in 2020 and if that wasn't enough her
powerful support of black lives matter
wearing masks on court in the 2020 u.s
open
with the names of black americans killed
due to police brutality
have put her in the headlines for all
the right reasons
i wanted to thank you glammer so much
for this award it really means a lot to
me and
just to be nominated as you know a
category a sports game changer
it's definitely very exciting and
touching so thank you so much
when this next woman was expecting she
discovered how little
femme tech was truly meeting the needs
of women so she did what any woman does
fixed it herself setting up lv in 2013
and launching with two revolutionary
products
a discrete breast pump and a pelvic
floor trainer that
unlike my last three boyfriends actually
works
in 2019 she raised the largest ever
amount for a single funding round in
femtech at 42 million dollars
our technology game changer is the
tenacious
tanya bowler hi everyone i am
tanya bola founder and ceo
of lv and we're all about creating
smarter technology
for women as soon as i started being in
this space and seeing that actually when
it came to women's health
all technology was horribly designed and
nothing really
as bad as the breast pump i don't know
how many of you familiar with the old
architecture but
big painful noisy cumbersome difficult
to use
so so what if we could design something
completely silent
put it in your bra let go and the app
does it for you
and that was our ambition and what we
managed to achieve with lb pump
the world's first silent wearable breast
pump but it has been a long journey
which is why it is so exciting and i'm
just so thrilled on behalf of the team
to be accepting this grammar award for
tech
game changer of the year it means so
much of us to be recognized by glamour
for the work that we're doing so thank
you very much
what a woman our next winner is a woman
who has had a hugely successful career
that spans almost 30 years
defying critics to turn herself from pop
star to fashion designer
just call her pivot spice and recently
added a best-selling beauty line to her
list of accolades
our fashion game changer is a multiple
time glamour cover star
it's the trailblazing victoria beckham
wow game changer um well thank you so
much glamour i'm not so sure i deserve
to be called a game changer but thank
you so much this really does mean
an enormous amount to me um over my
career
i've always tried to challenge the
status quo and never take no for an
answer so thank you so much this really
does mean an enormous amount to me
happy happy anniversary to everybody
at glamour and please stay safe and i
hope to see you all very
very soon but thank you so much this
means a while to me
happy birthday
our next award goes to someone who has
always used their platform as one of the
most recognizable and highest paid
models in the world
to put women's wellness on the map long
before it was cool
in 2019 she launched her own brand cora
organics in australia
and today is sold in over 30 countries
across the world
our wellness game changer is the
formidable
miranda kerr thank you so much glenna
this is so special i feel very honored
to be named
one of your women of the year it really
means so much to me
i'm sad we're not together to celebrate
but um actually one second
that's not stopping me from getting all
dressed up for you guys
no in all seriousness though thank you
so much
i'm just so passionate about health and
wellness and i have been
my whole life so to be recognized um
as a game changer in wellness really
just means so much to me
i'm just really proud to help people
realize that certified organic products
can deliver powerful results in a
healthy way
and my mission is to uplift and nurture
people every day
through powerful clean certified organic
products
thank you again glamour i am just so
grateful and so honored to
have this award sending so much love to
you all
our game changing actor has starred in
over 70 movies
and is perhaps the first person to make
the successful transition from bollywood
to hollywood after taking the lead role
in abc's tv drama quantico
but she's also been dedicated to
passionately supporting numerous causes
along the way
from working with unicef since 2006 to
setting up her eponymous foundation for
the health and education of children in
india
as well as campaigning for women's
rights across the world
congratulations to our winner priyanka
chopra jonas
i actually did not think that i would be
an actor
but i accidentally um i
sort of fumbled upon the pageant world
and
i suddenly went from being you know a
kid in
12th grade wearing a school uniform to
speaking the heads of states and
having opinions about economies around
the world
i'm the kind of person if you throw me
into the deep end i will
mostly try to swim
[Music]
the natural progression in india for
beauty queens that sort of won that kind
of title was hindi movies
my dad said are you do you want to do it
i said i'm curious
and he said well i never want you to
have a what if in your life
philanthropy has been a huge part of my
life not since i started my career but
since i was a child we were not patted
on our backs if we did something nice
it was just expected we were taught the
responsibility that comes with privilege
and then when
i won miss world and um i saw
what happens with a platform suddenly i
was talking to people about
things that i had only seen and
discussed with my parents
suddenly i could speak to people about
it and somebody else was writing it and
somebody made a donation and
changed someone's life and you know i
saw
the use i my voice could have
and that that really pivoted something
in my brain
and um it became a really important part
of what i did
i've been told many many times that i'm
insane for trying and i'll never make it
and
i'm you know i'm unconventional hence
i'll never make it and i realized
many years ago that the fact that you're
unconventional or that you have a dream
that is different than somebody else
makes it unique
in fact that's your strength well thank
you so much for the game changing actor
award
that means a lot to me
our next game changer isn't just a woman
she's an
institution and an ambassador for
greenpeace
who has always used her catwalks and
collections as a platform to campaign
for positive activism
for the past 20 years she's been an
active supporter for the environmental
justice foundation
friends of the earth amnesty
international and war
child among many others never when to
mince her words
our environmental game changer is the
extraordinary
dame vivian westwood thank you
glamour i am very proud
to accept this award
environmental game changer
i am the only person with a plan
to save the world from climate change
we have to do it within five years
support me follow me on
climaterevolution.com.uk
the friday speech the tuesday diary
love vivian
congratulations what an absolute icon
though i too have a plan i've been
saying for a long time that we should
take away beef and dairy farmers cattle
and replace those cows with bees bingo
bango fewer missions more delicious
honey no one's responding to my letters
and now for our game changer in music
this goes to a band who captured the
nation's hearts on x
factor in 2011 and who over the last
decade
have become a global phenomenon using
their voices not only to entertain
but to inspire and incite change across
mental health
racism and lgbtq plus rights
this is their first ever interview of
2021 as a trio
it's the hugely talented little mix
[Music]
well girls new year yeah the three of us
a trio
and can i just say it was nice going
into the new year as a three with the
number one single
[Music]
and it with a bang didn't we went in
with the bang i just want to say how far
we've come
right when we used to speak about being
feminists or anything like that like
anything
slightly political in the past i think i
remember us being on a red carpet
a long long time ago like nine ten years
ago at the beginning
and they were like oh are you feminist
and they put the mic to us and we were
like
and we panicked and we were so terrified
to speak about anything like that back
then but we also got told not to say
that we were feminists
it's very true so i think we always kind
of steered away from it and tried to
avoid the situation didn't we i think we
were just scared
we spent far too long being patronised
especially by like men in the
industry i don't know when it happened
but a sort of
switch happened between all of us really
actually no we're going to say what we
want i think it's getting used to like
we might say something wrong and we
might make a mistake but
being terrified to say anything at all
is worse well there's no change that
because then you're not going to learn
we're not going to learn we're not going
to
know more about all these things all
these issues in the world if we just sit
back and be like oh i'm just gonna say
anything
now that's not gonna help anyone i love
when we speak out
i love it girls give change
huge achievements and you know what
girls i think really deserve this i
think over the past couple of years
we've
really worked hard at finding ourselves
and being confident enough to speak out
on things we're passionate about whether
that's individually or as a group
and so it's really nice to be recognized
for that yeah
and grandma have helped us with that you
guys have always made us come out of our
shells
always made us feel safe in the
environment to speak how we feel about
all of our individual issues and what
we're going through so thank you guys so
much for being so supportive of us
over the whole all over the years and we
love you thank you
and to announce our final award of the
night please welcome back
deborah joseph thanks catherine and
catherine this next award goes to a
woman
who started out on our screens in the
1980s on australia's
longest running drama neighbours and has
gone on to have an insatiable pop career
selling over 70 million records
worldwide
winning numerous awards including a
grammy and three brits
and is the only ever artist to have had
a number one album in the uk
across five consecutive decades she's a
fervent campaigner for breast cancer
awareness
having survived herself and is a huge
supporter of lgbtq plus rights
she is the definition of reinvention the
princess of pop
and the only person to have had more wax
works made madam two swords is her
majesty the queen
our game-changing icon could only be the
inimitable
kylie minogue hello glamour thank you so
so so much for this recognition this is
truly unexpected
a total honor and i'm i am very much
humbled by this
thank you for giving me uh
an excuse to pause for a minute and
really reflect on
the many things that have got me to
where i am today the people the places
the tears that sometimes led to triumph
and i think the constant i've always had
and that i've really
fought for is is to not be boxed in to
really
be able to shape-shift and morph and
grow and develop and for that reason to
be part of your game changes
awards is very meaningful to me
if that can be encouraging to anyone to
follow their path
and to enjoy that voyage of
self-discovery
and and your place in the world that's
just amazing happy anniversary happy
20th to you
we've had a lot of fun over those 20
years and
i look forward to the next 20 so thank
you once again
and lots and lots of love
i hope you don't mind me jumping in i
also
wanted to express my heartfelt thanks to
all
the nhs frontline workers who continue
to pull out
all the stops to save lives and keep us
safe from the
doctors and nurses to the cooks cleaners
porters and care staff your actions over
the last year have been
truly heroic like so many others i've
been
blown away by your courage and
compassion and
by your incredible humanity and
unwavering dedication
as the mayor of london it's been one of
the most humbling experiences
of my life to speak to those brave nhs
staff in our city
you are the best of us it's my honor now
to hand over to some of our nhs
frontline workers from
northwick park hospital right here in
london
to accept the game changing award
thank you sadiq this has been a
challenging time for the country the
world
and our work has placed us at the center
of this pandemic
the and recognition from the public has
kept us going and motivated throughout
we don't see ourselves as heroes or
icons we're just normal people doing the
job that we feel passionately about
but we just want to say thank you uk
for this amazing award
[Music]
did you know the collective noun for a
group of sydney-based gay men is a
minogue
of gays and this dear audience is where
our evening ends
and like every good night we'll end
where we started at the free bar
wondering what's it gonna be like when
we're unleashed in a club and the dj
puts on [ __ ]
publicly for the first time yeah
wait has anyone actually seen a
bartender oh yeah i think one's due back
in
april thank you to all our awardees for
being so exceptional in your fields
during what has been a time that i'm
personally not
even gonna mention to my grandchildren
yeah i'll pretend the whole thing never
happened
like the trump presidency or that time i
agreed with pierce morgan on something
chilling now let's drink this bar dry
because no one else is gonna
bowling balling
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you